me mano a crea me ha querido centrar su
discurso sobre todo en tres ejes primero
la democracia velar por ella dentro de
la unión europea es básico asegurado
macrón y sobre todo también velar por el
estado de derecho ha recordado que hay
algunos países no los respetan sin
mencionarlo en una clara alusión a
países como polonia o hungría que
recientemente ha tenido varios problemas
con la unión europea por su vulneración
al estado de derecho por otra parte ha
hablado del progreso de la importancia
de que europa siga avanzando en
cuestiones como la lucha contra la
crisis climática y también a favor de la
digitalización y también ha hablado de
la seguridad a este respecto ha hablado
de la reforma del espacio schengen
recordemos es la zona de libertad de
circulación de personas dentro de la
unión europea y la importancia de
blindar las fronteras exteriores para
evitar crisis migratorias que
desestabilicen esta zona también ha
hablado de paz de la importancia de
dialogar sobre todo con rusia para
rebajar las tensiones por la frontera
con ucrania en líneas generales su
discurso ha sido bien recibido por todos
los grupos políticos
grupo popular ha pedido sin embargo que
en francia debe tener en cuenta que
europa debe ser cada vez más
independiente y depender menos de los
demás los socialistas también han dicho
que después que tras los discursos
bonitos y las bonitas palabras también
hay que tener hechos como por ejemplo la
lucha contra el cambio climático y el
rechazo a la energía nuclear ha habido
algún momento de tensión cuando el
candidato al elíseo del grupo de los
verdes y han hinchado que también está
eurodiputado ha hecho un encendido
discurso que ha provocado algún malestar
entre los diputados porque han
considerado que era un debate de campaña
electoral que no tenía cabida dentro del
parlamento europeo